DEMOCRAT OTHERWISE SAVE THE
COUNTRY.
LET NOT YOUR HEART BE TROUBLED.
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM AND
THIS IS THE LAURA INGRAHAM FROM
NEW YORK TONIGHT.
IN JUST EIGHT HOURS, THE FIRST
POLLS OF THE 2022 MIDTERMS OPEN
AND CANDIDATES ARE NOT LEAVING
ANYTHING ON THE FIELD.
>> WHO'S READY TO TAKE THIS
STATE BACK?
WHO'S READY TO SAVE THIS
COUNTRY?
>> THIS IS THE GREATEST COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD TODAY, AND IT'S
TIME, IT IS TIME FOR US TO SIGN
UP FOR AMERICA.
>> IF WE'RE ALL IN, WE WIN.
ALL IN?
>> WE WIN.
>> ALL IN?
>> WE WIN
>> AND ARE WE READY TOMORROW TO
TAKE BACK THIS COUNTRY?
>> ARE YOU READY TO TAKE THIS
STATE BACK?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> WHO'S READY TO SEND MARK
KELLY BACK TO SPACE TOMORROW?
>> Laura: NOW, WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM REPORTERS AND
CANDIDATES ACROSS THE NATION
TONIGHT INCLUDING OUR OWN MARK
MEREDITH IN OHIO WHERE DONALD
TRUMP IS STILL DELIVERING WHAT
WAS BILLED AS A HIGHLY
ANTICIPATED SPEECH.
BUT FIRST, THE GREAT
REALIGNMENT.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
>> WITH REPUBLICANS ABOUT TO
TAKE CONTROL OF BOTH THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE, MOST DEMOCRATS
AREN'T INTERESTED IN SERIOUS
SOUL SEARCHING ABOUT HOW IT ALL
UNRAVELLED.
FOR A BUNCH SO WORRIED ABOUT
ELECTION DENIAL, THEY SEEM TO BE
PREEMPTIVELY QUESTIONING THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE IMPENDING
REPUBLICAN TAKEOVER.
>> HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU THAT
THE UPHEAVAL AT TWITTER WILL
RESULT IN A FLOOD OF
MISINFORMATION, DISINFORMATION
RIGHT BEFORE THE ELECTION?
>> AND IT ACTUALLY GOES BEYOND
TWITTER.
TODAY THERE ARE REPORTS THAT, IN
FACT, RUSSIA BOTS NEWS REPORTS
HAVE COME BACK, OUTSIDE
INTERFERENCE COMING BACK.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THE REGIME
MEDIA AS ALWAYS PICKS UP THE
DEMOCRAT BATON AND RUNS WITH IT.
IN THE NEW YORK TIMES IT'S
RUSSIAN BOTS AND TROLLS AND
INTERFERENCE.
OH, MY.
WELL, THINK ABOUT THIS.
THE SAME GROUP THAT HAS BEEN
DRONING ON FOR YEARS ABOUT HOW A
VOTE FOR THEM IS A VOTE TO
PROTECT DEMOCRACY, WELL, WE NOW
SEE WHAT THEY REALLY MEANT BY
THAT.
DEMOCRACY ONLY WORKS WHEN THEY
WIN.
NOW, WE SHOULD ALWAYS ASSUME
THAT OUR ADVERSARIES ARE MUCKING
AROUND IN OUR SYSTEM.
IN FAN A RUSSIAN BUSINESSMAN
ADMITTED TODAY TO USING SOCIAL
MEDIA TO INFLUENCE ELECTIONS AND
IT ONLY STANDS TO REASON THAT
CHINA IS MEDDLING AS WELL BUT
TOO SOPHISTICATED TO GET CAUGHT
LET'S FACE IT.
BUT WHAT BIDEN AND HIS BRAND OF
REALITY DENIERS IGNORE IS THIS.
MOTHER RUSSIA OR CHINA OR ANY
OTHER FOREIGN COUNTRIES CREATED
THE PAIN ANY AMERICAN FAMILIES
ARE FEELING RIGHT NOW FROM
INFLATION AND THEY DIDN'T CAUSE
THE INCREASE IN VIOLENT CRIME IN
NEW YORK SUB WAYS.
AND PUTIN DIDN'T DESIGN THE
DEVIANT CURRICULUM.
BUT MORE SUBURBAN WOMENS
HISPANICS AFRICAN AMERICANS VOTE
REPUBLICAN IT'S NOT BECAUSE SOME
PUTIN INSPIRED DISINFO LURKING
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND TWITTER.
THAT PARADIGM SHIFT WILL OCCUR
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS MISREAD THEIR
MANDATE AND THREW IN WITH THE
FAR LEFT TO DESTROY OUR
PROSPERITY AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
THERE ARE A FEW DEMOCRATS,
THOUGH, WHO SEEM TO BE KIND OF
SORT OF GETTING IT.
>> I'M A LOYAL DEMOCRAT BUT I AM
NOT HAPPY.
I JUST THINK THAT WE ARE -- YOU
KNOW, WE DID NOT LISTEN TO
VOTERS IN THIS ELECTION AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A BAD
NIGHT AND, YOU KNOW, THIS
CONVERSATION'S NOT GOING TO HAVE
MUCH IMPACT ON TUESDAY BUT I
HOPE IT HAS AN IMPACT GOING
FORWARD.
BECAUSE WHEN VOTERS TELL YOU
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THAT THEY CARE MOSTLY ABOUT THE
ECONOMY, LISTEN TO THEM.
STOP TALKING ABOUT DEMOCRACY
BEING AT STEAK.
>> THAT'S NOT THE ONLY DEAFNESS,
THE ONLY QUICK SAND THAT THEY'RE
STEPPING INTO.
AS AMERICANS ARE FACING RECORD
HIGH PRICES FOR HEATING OIL THIS
WINTER, JOE BIDEN WENT AND HE
TOLD THE TRUTH OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> NO MORE DRILLING.
THERE IS NO MORE DRILLING.
>> Laura: OKAY, OLD MAN.
WELL, A FEW DAYS EARLIER HE
KNOCKED OFF THE ENTIRE COAL
INDUSTRY AS WELL.
>> NO ONE'S BUILDING NEW COAL
PLANTS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T RELY
ON IT.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SHUTTING THESE
PLANTS DOWN ALL ACROSS AMERICA
AND HAVING WIND AND SOLER.
>> Laura: SINCE WE ALREADY KNOW
ABOUT HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT
FRACKING FOR NATURAL GAS THEY'RE
AGAINST IT, WHERE DOES THIS
LEAVE US AS A NATION.
EVEN EVEN WITH THE HOT AIR
BLOWING IN DC IT'S NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH TO AMERICA.
SO IS BIDEN SETTING THE STAGE
FOR ANOTHER SELF IMPOSED
SHUTDOWN OF THE ENTIRE COUNTRY?
OIL, NATURAL GAS AND COAL ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR NEARLY 80% OF
AMERICAN ENERGY CONSUMPTION.
SO WITHOUT THAT, LIFE AS WE KNOW
IT IN THE UNITED STATES WILL
COME TO A SCREECHING HALT.
FOLKS, THIS IS THEIR CLOSING
MESSAGE, AND THE SO-CALLED
MASTER COMMUNICATOR BARACK
OBAMA, HE DIDN'T DO MUCH BETTER.
BEFORE HE HEADED OUT ON THE
TRAIL FOR THE DEMOCRATS, HE MUST
HAVE HAD, I DON'T KNOW, A
SPOTIFY CREATE SOME KIND OF PLAY
LIST BASED ON JOHN LENNON'S SONG
IMAGINE.
>> IMAGINE IF WE HAD BEEN ABLE
TO FIX OUR BROKEN IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM BACK IN 2011?
IMAGINE IF WE HAD BEEN ABLE PASS
MEANINGFUL GUN SAFETY
LEGISLATION.
IMAGINE IF WE HAD BEEN ABLE TO
REDUCE OUR EMISSIONS IF WE HAD
KEPT THE SENATE IN 2014 WE WOULD
HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT SUPREME
COURT MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT OUR
MOST BASIC RIGHTS.
>> Laura: IMAGINE IF MARTHA'S
VINEYARD WANTED TO KEEP THOSE
MIGRANTS ALL 50 OF THEM.
IMAGINE THAT.
IMAGINE IF YOU HAD A DEMOCRAT
PARTY THAT WASN'T SO OUT OF STEP
WITH OUR MIDDLE CLASS, OUT OF
STEP WITH HISPANICS AND
INDEPENDENT VOTERS.
LET'S IMAGINE THAT.
NOW IT'S REALLY BEEN SOMETHING
TO BEHOLD.
THE PARTY THAT TANKED OUR GDP IN
LESS THAN TWO YEARS, THE PARTY
THAT GOT US INTO A POINTLESS
PROXY WAR WITH RUSSIA, THE PARTY
THAT PLAYED BY THE -- GOT PLAYED
BY THE SAUDIS ON OIL PRODUCTION,
IS NOW CLAIMING TO BE THE
CHAMPIONS FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS?
>> THE MIDDLE CLASS GETS STIFFED
AND THE POOR GET POORER UNDER
THEIR POLICY.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED LAST TIME
UNDER MY PREDECESSOR.
THE ECONOMY WAS IN RUINS.
HE LOST MANUFACTURING JOBS AND
HUNDREDS OF SMALL BUSINESS HERE
IN THIS STATE AND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND NATIONWIDE.
>> Laura: THE ELLOCUTION
NOTWITHSTANDING LIAR LIAR PANTS
ON FIRE.
UNDER TRIM WE HAD THE STRONGEST
MEADE YES, MA'AM INCOME IN TWO
DECADES AND BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
THEY HAD THE HIGHEST GDP GROWTH
IN THE G-7 NOW WE'RE SIXTH AND
FOUGHT HIS OWN PARTY'S
ESTABLISHMENT TO GET ON TOUGH ON
CHINA'S TRADE ABUSES.
BUT NICE TRY, JOE.
LET'S FACE IT, IT'S TOUGH TO BE
A DEMOCRAT THIS MIDTERM.
THE LIES EVENTUALLY CATCH UP TO
YOU PRETTY QUICKLY AND THEIR
PARTY'S ELDERS, WHO ARE ABOUT TO
LOSE THEORY CHAIRMANSHIPS ARE
GETTING VERY CRANKY.
SO CRANKY THAT THEY'RE SKIPPING
THE RACE CARD AND GOING RIGHT TO
THE NAZI CARD.
>> I STUDIED HISTORY ALL OF MY
LIFE.
>> OKAY.
>> I TAUGHT HISTORY AND I'M
TELLING YOU WHAT I SEE HERE ARE
PARALLELS TO WHAT THE HISTORY
WAS THIS WORLD BACK IN THE 1930s
IN GERMANY, IN ITALY.
>> Laura: IT'S HARD TO CALL
SOMEONE A NAZI WHEN YOU'RE ABOUT
TO GO TO A LIEU OW.
IT'S VERY HARD.
THIS IS WHEN YOU KNOW THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO GET
SHELLACKED WHEN CONSERVATIVES
ACTUALLY FOCUS ON THE ISSUES
THAT VOTERS CARE ABOUT, IT IS A'
NOW FASCIST?
THAT'S THEIR CLOSING MESSAGE?
AND I HAVE THIS SIMPLE QUESTION,
DID DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY PAY SOME
CONSULTANT SOMEWHERE FOR THIS
CAMPAIGN ADVICE?
NOW WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHERE
THINGS END UP IN THIS ELECTION
BUT ONE THING IS FOR SURE.
THE FUTURE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS THE SAME AS WHAT I SAID
IT WAS ON ELECTION NIGHT 2020
WHEN I WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE SAME COALITION WE SAW IN
FLORIDA BACK IN 2020, A RISING
POPULOUS COALITION THAT TAKES
THE SOLID REPUBLICAN BASE AND
ADDS MORE WORKING PEOPLE, MORE
HISPANIC VOTERS, MORE SUBURBAN
WOMEN AND MORE PEOPLE ON THE
COAST TIRED OF ECONOMIC CHAOS,
THAT IS GETTING STRONGER.
FOR 12 YEARS EVER SINCE THE RISE
OF THE TEA PARTY THIS COALITION
HAS BEEN GAINING STRENGTH.
FIRST WE STOPPED OBAMA, THEN WE
DEFEATED HILLARY, THEN WE HELPED
DONALD TRUMP REACH THE WHITE
HOUSE.
WE HELD TOGETHER THROUGH COVID,
THROUGH LIES THROUGH ATTACKS ON
THE BIG BUSINESS COMMUNITY, FROM
THE REGIME MEDIA AND NOW WE'RE
COMPETITIVE ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I HOPE, AND I BELIEVE, THAT
TOMORROW WILL BE A GREAT NIGHT
FOR THE REPUBLICANS AND THE
REPUBLIC.
BUT WE'RE NOT FINISHED YET.
AMERICANS ARE READY FOR PEACE
AND PROSPERITY.
THEY'RE READY FOR A CONGRESS AND
A PRESIDENT THAT WOR